[Musique]
en 2009 la moitié 7 milliards à guiglo
yvon et certaines villes telles que
shanghai pékin séoul ou encore les
gosses au plus de 10 millions d'années
vous imaginez ville pour parce que la
population comme pays levait qui dans
ses salles le résident en mai parce que
tout le monde pouvait imaginer alors
pouette affrontant d'ici 2050
les deux tiers de la population mondiale
puis revendu les riverains conclut
peuple mais savez vous savez vous que
notre milieu de lui détermine nos
habitudes à ce qu'ils nous permettent de
quitter notre milieu haut à notre
commune des angles très saine de
quelqu'un qui vit en ville et le cadeau
qui les y en eut dans une agglomération
celui qui vit en ville le brass leurs
tréteaux ou se rendent au travail à
l'heure à quoi du trafic routier très
dense
contrairement à celui qui vit en
agglomération qui n'aura pas à se
soucier du trafic routier
on pourra donc qu on s'auto où se rendra
aujourd'hui je viens vous parler comme
vous l'auriez déjà pu deviner la ville
et vient du fichier je viens partager ma
conviction
que s'intéresser aux vies on sait la
ville du futur ne devrait pas être une
tâche exclusivement réservé aux
surveillances s'intéresser aux villes du
futur devait naître la chaire de tous
oui vous nouveau nouveau et de moi ou
bien n'avez vous pas envie de savoir si
d'ici 20 30 assez content nous vivons
dans des villes sous terre sur l'eau
dans l'air elle vous qu'on lui de savoir
si nous aurons des voitures volantes
est ce que nous aurons toujours des
arbres des animaux
est-ce que l'eau potable serait
accessible à tous est ce qu'il y aurait
assez de logements pour tout le monde
déjà qu aujourd'hui d'un milliard de la
population mondiale vit dans des
habitations informel généralement
appelée taudis bidonvilles ou favelas ce
sens aux infrastructures de base sans
assainissement et ceci dans nos villes
en tout cas moi ça méliès il ment parce
que je suis urbaniste et que je
travaille pour l'accès à la ville pour
tous mais parce que je vais zito vie et
que je désire y rester tout comme la
plupart d'un faux et c'est fini comme à
l'habitude de lui dire au visage et le
futur il est important de comprendre le
passé et le présent
alors je vous propose de faire un saut
spatio temporel à travers les images
aller soi de moshe pis vous n'en avez
pas
ok c'est pas grave vim une prime une
comptine en afrique pays peinaient
débarquement littoral il côtoie alors le
deux images que vous voyez la ville de
toulouse a plus précisément la zone de
l'étoile rouge à deux époques tiff et
1981 pour la première de 2016 pour la
souris vous conviendrez avec moi comme
1980 les habitations dans la ville de
caudry et plus précisément la zone de
l'étoile rouge étaient dispersés on
vraiment en 2016
elles sont plutôt structure
intertechnique nous dirons que cotonou
en 2016 mieux planifier cotonou en 1981
de la même manière la population cotonou
en 2016 et veracruz fois celle de
cotonou en 1904 ceci juste pour vous
montrer à quel point les échanges et que
leur population sa croissance et c'est
affreusement de la population urbaine
encore appelée urbanisation qui est avec
son lot de problèmes
le challenge est de défis pour la vie
actuels tels que les inondations
le manque de logement adéquat pour tous
l'inaccessibilité à l'eau potable ces
personnes et génisses
après ce
o dans le passé et se fait dans le
présent faisons maintenant on le
retrouve à l'écriture cette vidéo vous
donnera un avant goût de ce à quoi
ressemblerait les villes du futur
je vous ai dit à la cif alors bienvenue
dans la ville
comme je le disais tantôt la vidéo ou
donnera une avant goût de ce afin de
sauver la ville du futur seront de vie
cette vive fertile cette vidéo nous
donne espoir que dans la ville du futur
nous avons encore des tables nous aurons
encore les animaux vient du futur c'est
la ville dans lesquelles nous n'aurons
plus de chefs de deux sachets plastiques
n'auront plus de déchets un peu partout
dans nos villes parce qu'il existerait
déjà la poubelle publique veut pas tout
la poubelle qui seront dotés de capteurs
qui enverront des signaux au service de
collecte seront pleins guen et cette
technique se fait déjà aux marins et
d'ici quelques mois le bébé aussi fera
pareil à à la société de gestion de
vichy l'avion du futur
ces deux villes dans lesquelles n'ont eu
à passer the dans le trafic routier ou à
ce qu'il y aurait déjà une diversité de
systèmes de transport outils et mieux
nous aurons la voiture de l'homme et de
la voiture tellement une religion
qu'elle pourrait mieux nous éduquer le
idéal qu'est la maison ou au rock au
polo à l'heure et le meilleur itinéraire
ou les larrieu du futur et les villes
jonché de tours équipés de micros
apparemment dans le but de loger le
maximum de baisse
le viol du futur défi à lesquels
technologie est omniprésente
oui la technologie sera comme l'air que
nous respirons la ville du futur cd
ville connectée
je suis très impatient de 8 10 et mais
vous vous pensez vous que vous aurez
assez assez vite
pensez vous que vous aurez la
possibilité de ville de séville ou c'est
vous que les murs du futur seraient
assez planes tous celui du futur sera
associé à toutes les couches sociales ou
serait-elle simplement les et réaliste
la réponse à cette question où elle est
positive et les villes du futur est
accessible à tous mais à une seule
condition qu'elle soit réussie et
l'inclusion 11 de l'état
en effet et ça vaut j'ai eu la chance
d'aller aux états unis où j'ai appris ça
à l'initiation le planification ou là
une session d'écouté publique organisée
par la commission de la planification
d'une vie et j'ai vu des habitants
séries venues exposer à la commission
les problèmes les défis et les
challenges auxquels vidéo volée face aux
à certaines décisions
mais ici j'aime y ait pas que nous avons
la chance d'être éditée à ces signes ont
vécu public à cesser dé planification
nous nous disons cela ne nous concerne
pas puisque nous sommes nés urbanistes
il n'y eu lieu et nous avons nous avons
encore puisque nous vivons dans les
villes toutes les décisions qui sait par
rapport aux huiles nous affecterons
d'une manière ou tués
allais-je a fait pas une fois à une
session de panification de salé et le
res cela veut dit que la plupart d'entre
nous avons jamais pris part à une
session de fabrication de vie pourtant
nous vivons nos mairies écoutant ses
sources sont généralement au métro unis
alors c'est vous chacun de nous ici
prise au jeu se sentir à tous niveaux du
jeu proche et que nous avons je pense
qu'ils vont adorer
nous les a pris de jeu aux femmes en
font via handicapées ou bien photo ichou
peau devons commencer à nous intéresser
un peu plus et on commence déjà à fond
pas à ces sessions de qualifications qui
sont ouverts au public
et si par hasard ces cessions ne sont
pas programmées dans nos villes nos
poumons déjà écrit nos rêves vos
aspirations blainville du budget et si
nous avons dessiné cet inconnu est votre
vision plainview et signer vos
aspirations vous plaît écrivez le
problème majeur où vous aimeriez que la
municipalité adresse à son prochain
projet et allait les déposer au service
de la place de la mairie
il se chargera en sautant le les
intégrer au plan de développement de
l'aisne je disais tantôt que la ville du
futur
c'est la vie dans lesquelles la
technologie est omniprésente
attention aux leaders à différents
niveaux aurait alors utilisé cette
révolution des oeillets 6 améliorer leur
communication avec nous
déjà en communiquant assez vous êtes
session de qualifications afin de
toucher le maximum de personnes
mais également avec toutes les couches
sociales soient représentés au coude et
c'est l'image qui définissent mutu de
ceux ci ou que de mai nous n'ayons pas
simplement et celui des budgets et david
plaisir à cécile à tous delic
[Applaudissements]